MARY POPPINS y'all was he cool yes he
was movies great pretty river view yeah
right but a beer cuz I lose a beer kind
of movie thanks Annie
I just I don't know why half the
residents like because it's it's late
now we saw like an evening show so I'm
just like huh just want a beer now like
just chill come off that kind of high
yeah man so good its I just have yeah we
should clarify what we thought the first
film uh I know you really loved in why
you say oh it's still one of my fit one
of my favorite movies that I've seen in
like a decade see and I liked it I
thought was good I thought was fun uh
you know but I feel I didn't quite get
into as everyone else I really got into
this one ah see that's funny yeah yeah I
could press on there yeah that this one
that this one was so good um but to me
it's it's we're splitting hairs like I
know yeah I feel like if to me the first
one was in a movie then this one's like
it is a good B+ be like yeah it is well
you know what I like my I think my wife
was the same way we were talking about
on the way back and she she liked this
one better and I'm I will say this I
think this one had more character like
ain't trying to flesh out these guys a
little more than men and just joke and
when the time came to for the most part
when the time came for them to talk and
be their characters and stuff like that
it didn't seem to quite come right out
of nowhere it seemed like it was a
little bit more woven in for the most
part learn about part
Erica for really cheesy seeds read like
err yeah and there's a couple hammer on
the head like yeah we got it you know
she goes to have with my favorite lines
now in any movie ever which is what are
you talking about all you guys do is
just yell and scream at each other he's
right we're not friends we're family
nothing like that good there's never
been a truer statement set uh yeah and
even like the little bullshit action
scene in the opening that's usually for
no reason in these movies you know it's
just like you know
it's like the start you get to talking
saying okay the white wine opens up it
actually is tied together gun takes the
cliche it's the gang back together again
we're not like in the middle of some
battle scene and completely runs wild
with it and it's great because it is it
has nothing to do with the battle going
on it's no is that's my favorite thing
that is ever like it's all in the
background and what's going on what's
going on in the foreground at school
like I don't know like it we should give
it a layer I'm gonna say article a but
may I say that you know the first great
way the first couple minutes I was
almost like not liking was bad I was
getting a little concerned cause I'm
like okay young CGI the gang back
together I could see drop you in the
middle and I was like oh he'll get in it
like I said we're dead look yo the two
nuts that action scene started and you
see the angle they're going with it it's
like okay we're for good we're gonna
intro before the action scene was just
quick and just goofy and light-hearted
enough in the way it was done that I was
okay with it but I did have the same
thought I'm just like really we're doing
the the young yet can the old actor look
young again I don't remember being bad I
mean with all that I'm a carpet it I
look at it as I said to show off there's
there is kind of a once again I feel
like some of these Marvel movies do nail
it in a certain way just where there's
kind of almost an excuse word where you
could buy why it doesn't look quite
right White's got the uncanny valley
look I'm like okay like maybe I could
see this because the whole it's later
I'm like I'm like hey man you might have
just got away with that Marvel like
versus someone reserves like no this is
supposed to be real you can't he'll be
different like and you know here it's
like any can reason oh yeah so this
whole you know and the whole movie is
like a lot of these day and Marvel
movies it's basically doing what Marvel
movies - we've seen this dozens of times
now but they find a unique fun
interesting way that you're with it and
you love these characters and anytime to
cut to a different one I'm never like oh
no not this
I earn as a woman is I know it's like
I'm always curious what's going on no
and this must be what it felt like
because this know what it is missing
versus Star Wars is the mystical there's
no really mystical element in any of
this that's just we have I'll be on it
yet but this must be what it felt like
because we were too young really I mean
Star Wars of 77 I was going to be born
yet for a couple years it must be what
it felt like to watch Star Wars of a
first I mean just to have that feeling
of I want to live in this universe
yeah universe feels real it feels fun I
want to live in it and the only one I
can think of off the top of my head that
did that in at the same time for us in
high school probably Fifth Element was
the other one I could think of words
like you know this you know where you
know there might be another one but this
universe feels so complete and real and
lived in there's a couple I'll say like
the avatar that not such shitty blue
kitties the The Last Airbender world
over
oh I grew up Island yeah I'm talking
about to like kind of just experiences
like high school age like what have we
seen high school us at a fifth element
that could compete uh ma'am yeah it is
it may be like the behind again I Roger
Rabbit I want it to happen that 90s were
a dead zone for sci-fi for a while too
so in what what Independence Day um but
but yeah so it's like it's that same
feeling I gave watching something like
stardate or even there instantly like
men in black was another good example of
like I just love this universe like even
though it was still earth it's like this
like interrogate is what is it yeah what
did I I don't know I just know like it
can't be stargates oh sorry mr. Russell
still winnable ask all right I guess
late
men and men in black is what I meant to
say you know in this movie ultimate it
could be this exhausting like when it
was the I treated I don't want to talk
about that cool pants my issue yeah
it is a and you could call it guardians
of excess and kind of there be
unforgiving to be chopped off ten
minutes yeah and it's just in the climax
like it's it's good in that by a like
where all you don't need all
inventiveness and all of the goodwill
that he is built up to that point kind
of got checked out a bit because the
best thing in the climax is Groot and
his rocket trying to explain the GRU how
to work the damn bomb that scene works
just as I know it was in the trailers
everywhere but that scene works even
better when you see it in context like
it's hilarious yeah that is the best
scene isn't didn't climax
I don't got some other stuff no the rest
of it the rest of it was like fine but
it's all shit that I'm just like yes I
sat through Man of Steel I sat through
bat members who I've sat through the
avenge when they good like a humor I
thought it yeah when they put in the
humor but that but that's the thing that
scene where he's explaining the bomb and
star-lord keeps like going away asking
for scotch tape and you just hear it you
don't see the battle you just see
rockets like reactions like oh my god
like you know I love always just crash
this is never great little bit better
than anything you saw in that climax
visually cuz cuz like your man wailing I
mean they're not giving anything away
come on that oh no ok there is one bad
one right it really is there is one
brilliant visual joke I will say this
better than anything in pixels I know
spoilers just better than anything in
pixels um so yeah no I mean but there's
a little joke but you know what I'm
saying it's like we don't have a sky
portal but it may as well have been the
second cousin to the sky part I've just
had that same explosion rocks in the sky
you know kind of you know I and it was
bad I'm not I'm not saying it was an
awful climate it's better than 90% of
the climaxes of this place you could
hide in half you could cut it in a half
and after so many other scenes were so
freaking inventive the Londos girl was
at Mondrian though I've read a column
I go worker blue guy has the best
dancing and they him and rocket um I
don't give too much weight let's just
say they they get their shit back um
and okay is the way it is time to the
music and the way it goes down it is one
of the most fucking psychotic things
I've ever seen
I mean that's me with psycho wasn't that
what you really think about what happens
in it you know I wanna shit but what the
me but that's the thing them you did up
beat music the ironic music choices
everything attached to it just makes it
so much funnier and also kind of darker
like I just love that whole scene I feel
like this movie went darker too
yeah I'm a result like I and what I like
is that I'm almost saying to myself that
this is too dark this is not warranted
but then it does become warranted like
all that stuff does about man in the
middle it ends there's an explosion near
the end and everything but they've seen
the middle was the case of it there
wasn't a whole lot go it's an arrow like
this yeah that's it like I think we got
the climax and I'm just like yeah it was
alright climax but it's just like just
that is the only amount thing just
because you you know could doesn't mean
that you should and this was like well
we could blow up whole planets and do
this I'm like that's fine but bigger
isn't necessarily better or wasn't none
that was the best scene in the movie the
bed oh yeah the best thing in the movie
were just more inventive shit that was
like on a lower scale and I'm very money
honestly the stuff I remember the most
in the climax is again what the
characters were going through and
eventually I don't remember that much I
remember a lot of visuals from this
movie like this is a gorgeous movie but
how much of it is explody Planet finale
not much verses yeah that's that's my
point in this outside of it someone's
got you know a couple of skills decipher
so yeah you go see cobalt and drops from
white star fox well yeah can't see but
I'm like okay I know watching a movie
like a talking raccoon but you're you
live in me a little bit but but again I
mean it's because the characters are so
strong and so good and I just love
watching them and I really legitimately
care for all of them uh that's what got
me through despite all the excess
because this I swear to God and it's so
weird because if you ask me I'm like
yeah I like the movie but if you ask me
well how was like how did you feel
during it I would tell you it is a
little Moria sleep aced sometimes there
are just times I'm just like I like what
I'm seeing but the same time Christ this
feels slow like just seems like and I
don't know how to fix it because I'm
just like they're not necessarily bad
but I'm just I felt it way more in this
film versus the other one yak that event
is like a two-hour button plus movie I
know exactly what you're talking about
there are still scenes where it's like
to me it's like I almost felt like that
like when they would stop and just talk
about what they're going through
I'm oh I'm kind of feeling like okay
we're doing this be well these scenes
are usually about five to eight minutes
so hopefully but then they keep it
really short and really tight okay okay
so it's like I'm not bored by maybe
that's it I would feel like I'm about to
be bored and then never quite happen but
always here and that is the difference
because in the first one I never felt I
was about to be born
in this one I felt like I was about to
be born wasn't really bored so as I said
like if people are going to stomp on me
for this I mean we're just splitting
hairs yeah I got money okay at this
point but it wasn't like look for the
one with the hair complaint no I was
about to be born
yeah Holly if you wanted like your
movies do we say that about very few
almost album is like no we would just
were born yeah it's only kind of
standard movie thing uh you know I mean
again without giving away you know too
much there is you know a thing about you
know an abandon a parent and which I
feel like is that's kind of like the new
thing being done in a lot of movies and
shows like exams right there but before
you who is your real perrolli I feel
like being done a lot and that's intra I
think it's a retelling of the times now
you know there's like and I think it's a
good message to have but the same time
as soon as it starts you are kind of
like oh we're doing this thing but the
way they do it is so much fun and so
interesting and downright surreal when
you find out who Kurt Russell is I'll
tally really we're doing this um okay
and I mean I have a major I have a major
advantage did you know some people know
that's the thing I considered an
advantage not knowing jack-shit going in
because I didn't have garden living a
saying like I know there are some people
who read the comics that are just like
Anton at the same I'm like that's fine
that's not me I never read them so I
can't sit here and complain yeah so I
like when I don't know where was going I
was doing like who he is what he is and
stuff I'm like I'm this is so strange
I'm like tell me more like this is so
bizarre but it's just it it's still
holding me it's keeping me in method
this is a fucking pretty movie that
planet is emit I could look at every
single burial in that planet and and you
know what it is is gun knows how or at
least is cinema Tigers oh how to compose
a fucking shot I think of all the like I
like your some action in here that gets
a little sloppy but for the most part
like compared to a Michael Bay film or
something is like I knew what was going
on I could like just stare at whole
scenes and just make out little tiny
details like they're just every single
scene is covered in shit but unlike
other movies where you feel like it's
just so much shit they just threw on the
screen this is just so meticulously
crafted every single frame there is a
trailer for the next ain't your last
Transformers movie uh and you know it
just felt like I was short now it just
felt like I was watching a blur it's
just nothing I just watched nothing with
a few explosions of musical go home
important whole transformers is before
yeah uh err Doug it's got Anthony
Hopkins in Optimus Prime
uh and again the same stupid shit here
but it's like hey you wanna make
Transformers fun watch guardians of the
galaxy and do that you know remember fun
not optimus probably oh I don't know I
must not sure a my kind of let's kill
them all it's like no this is fun and it
has the drama surprisingly there's a lot
of legit like tug at your heartstrings
Mullins in fucking guardians of the
galaxy too we're just to look at it's
like if films had an afterglow would
look like Guardian to like you just get
kind of swept up in there like ah like
it's just just feels great man you don't
like a good round what could I tell you
and it's kind of like uh it's almost
like middle-earth it's like it lets you
stay there for a while you know I mean
that's always kind my favorite parts of
the Lord range misses when you get the
kind of resume in these beautiful place
it doesn't shy away from any of the
locations and it's one of the weird sets
of films where the production design is
just goofy enough that the fact that CGI
is never still to this day looked 100
percent quite real actually helps this
film because it looks like a comic book
is what a few films rhymed is like you
know what I don't care that it's CGI is
actually helping this universe
yeah um there were anyone there is
impressive CGI in this movie too is
there are a lot of times around like oh
oh yeah generally looks like that
raccoon is there oh yeah no I'm not and
I'm not even talking about rock and I'm
just talking about some of those special
- baby animals and stuff I'm just like
yeah you know if this were another movie
or like a movie we're know that's
supposed to be like photorealistic I'm
supposed to leave it's actually there
like that's Howard the Duck in it yeah
you know you know what it is
the second is like you know III this
universe like it's more it's more of a
Futurama universe then like a normal
kind of sci-fi universe where I'm
supposed to take it super seriously and
so the CGI honestly is one of the rare
times where it helps and you're not
going to see me complaining about it if
I have to pick one other nitpick again
it is a nitpick I'm surprised a lot of
times in this movie the dramatic scenes
the dramatic scenes have surprisingly
goofy moments in them uh most of them
involving David Hasselhoff and like 90%
of them work but that 10% that doesn't
sometimes I'm thinking particularly but
there's one involving his mother and
then this David Hasselhoff joke comes
almost immediately after I'm like you
needed like 10 more seconds before you
did that like that that was like a huge
big reveal then suddenly at the table
hang on I honestly that didn't bother me
much just because I felt like the tone
of this got set up in the first film is
so goofy for the most part of for
something that opened with cancer yeah
but the rest of it was so goofy that I
feel that without interjecting some
humor and the Marvel haha moment it
starts to feel like on a very special
episode of full house no and that's
repair know like let's give out the the
soft guitar music and have a moment so I
mean I'm kind of glad that they kind of
kept it don't you it's those one or two
times where I'm like yeah the timing was
just like a hint off you know but yeah I
feel like I'm really digging with that
and I guess that I mean without giving
away too much the villain would be great
if they didn't do this plan in every
other Marvel movie it's Jesse it's like
I would actually love this villain if it
wasn't be yes and going to consumes
life's destroyed because it is I'm too
smart for my own good the greater
purpose some reputable good yeah and
it's just like I would love this about
the occasion where this were villain
from 20 years ago I'd be like oh my god
if this one were made in 1980 where it
starts then this would have been an
amazing village now it is all Iran if
you know lochia its all those you know
all those things um so that gets a
little but but again I think a lot of
things from like a storytelling
perspective you've seen a million times
in these Marvel movies but it's done
with these characters with these great
visuals and with just a bizarre
storytelling that's unique and not it
finds different points in the night I
just realized this while watching this
movie because now they're owned by
Disney but this is what Disney movies
used to be like the live-action films
where is like yeah this kind of a
standard formula yeah they're kinda
everybody I and the animated films well
I think about how Disney had a quality
to the live-action films in the old days
um you know I I feel like this is like
strangely enough by grabbing Marvel this
is a return to that it's like yeah
you're gonna see kind of a set formula
but the mouse will be damned if you're
not entertained because he wants your
money
no and you know you're gonna get a fun
ride pretty much no matter what that's
what old like live-action Disney movies
like you know 20,000 Leagues Under the
Sea Mary Poppins but not and Bruce's
let's not jump you maritime Mary Poppins
y'all a marathon yeah if that's what
they used to be it's like funny this was
the modern equivalent of it this is the
new set of wimax yeah moving on to the
Marvel films like it's good we're too
early on Star Wars to know if it's going
to be the case there we've only had two
so but at least with Marvel now we've
got this wrong steady Street where it's
like I'm trying to get yeah there's been
some bad ones but I haven't come out of
it going oh I love that film to the
point that like yeah well I like Iron
Man 2 it's like I can't remember that
damn films yeah Thor 2 for me from yeah
but I didn't but I'm trying to there was
a Marvel film Disney Marvel and yes I
have come out of it was like fucking ice
dam over go to hell yeah like not really
it's just more like me
yeah I like it doesn't hit an emotion
he's kind of leaving please Ironman
Tuesday make me angry I was just like oh
I wish a lot more cool self analyst yeah
I just I just like left a favor look
what happened yeah Mickey Rourke an
electron whip that's all I never said
parrot
otama see parrot or something is you
know and there's a detail I just got you
this good but so many crappy guy give
this movie first of all they know how to
use a cash demon song to say really oh
yeah and you know how to use all the
songs that they use but the details that
they had upon them just like wow yeah I
mean I thought about this in years
they had these shift this is actually
very clever to keep the pg-13 rating all
these ships are fly by and they're
shooting low but they're all from you
know they're being their control yeah
they're drone and all these people are
play and they have arcade sounds yeah
that was review that I could not stop
laughing during that fuck how do you
build arcade says but the detail they
got is that because you know there's not
really our case anymore you know but
while we were growing up they had these
arcades and there is always the big game
it was like you know in a moral Kombat 2
or 3 fighter 2 and always the expert
yeah yeah and they're going to crowd
around and coolers blossom around and
they would watch them do their thing
until my loss I tell me losses like back
and then won't he did it and they heavy
arcade was like pac-man sound effects
gonna away from I draw breath yeah I'm
not seein okay that was one of my
favorite season threw it up it's like
and it made me realize I'm like holy
shit can you imagine if America has that
ability that would be serious it's like
no it's just like an arcade game you get
a whole group of like Gen Xers and
Millennials just like blown the shit out
of nations with our willing we're
halfway there we got it groans man yeah
oh yeah you could argue be kind of this
a geeky sized what we're halfway there
but on the scale you saw with this thing
everybody in the same room like this
giant like oh wow that is both insanely
hilarious and a dark portent of things
to activate
but yeah that sounds amazing um direct I
think got on here uh yes Drax is still
funny about Rockets great with it oh my
god so in the middle of the movie my
wife turns me and says a lot of baby
Groot and I'm just like who down the
road is like great baby Groot is like
the Duke girls
yeah everyone just loved you like yeah
but I think we all like him better than
cock see what yeah I I want hug baby
through it I want to see I want put
Gollum like in a shelter to get food or
something like that
I still want directed to the Shelf baby
Groot is amazing Gamora has got some
great scenes um go go let me set up with
this sister yeah I actually even forgot
she had a sister I know she was I was
looking at selecting her ready to come
back so that was that I met there
interesting the romance between her and
Pratt Alec Alec yeah oh the rumor is the
third one's going to be more Gamora
based if this one was more star-lord
based so I'm interested to see that
because it's one more sort of I mean
it's like I feel like they all get equal
say you know they all get equal screen
time but it's all anchoring on him
though because the toon search for his
father that basically affects everything
else around them so I mean I don't know
but I did like the way they did kind of
connect it all of those family kind of
longings and then yeah so he might have
much on the head yeah kind of all
connected together better than I thought
it was going yeah I'm just like huh I
was like really I expected and not
really to connect at all I don't wanna
make some side stories in the star-lord
and I'm like yeah that weird there's all
kind of like just barely like it was a
little rough but I'm like yeah yeah she
kind of tied it together I was I was
really a guy who helped write scooby-doo
and I was really expecting the same
thing like okay here's all these side
things and they're fun but this is just
going to be a side thing this is just
going to be okay and then they're going
to come together at the end for the
climax it's not my best but it's like
they are you know without you guy
weaving is a very closing web but it is
still a web and it lets us come together
I just
my wife watches Gilmore Girls so Sean
Gunn the directors brother like plain I
thought I knew they had to be somebody's
uh yeah I said to him so who's laying
yonder why he was second in command but
he was one of the UH those friends
basically oh yeah you know I'm talking
about I don't want to give too many
spoilers away but like my wife and I
were just laughing because I like to
think that it's the same character he
preys on Gilmore Girls
and then he's just like some alien
hanging out and stars huh look like my
wife I were working on the way home this
whole backstory this all connects to the
Marvel you first and the Oh best best
like hands-down best I guess I voted no
I don't know how you top at best Stan
Lee cameo ever I don't I don't know
you're gonna do it if you know the
comics and you know what it's
referencing it's brilliant yeah I don't
know I don't think you can top it and
like and this is it explains everything
I'm like there you go it's already kind
of what people were talking about but
then never clarified and this is right
there it's not insanely clever in the
way because like everybody's head but
but they did it they actually did it and
put it in a movie and you Stan Lee as
the cameo and I'm like frickin brilliant
man let it get just looking up timing of
it going through mm-hmm you know just
travel all these all this crazy shit is
flying by you and then suddenly there's
this and it's just like gasps that's
great yeah oh yeah the colors the action
for the most purposes he's kind of he's
got a keen eye for like kinetic energy
and a shot like he moves the camera
sometimes like Peter Jackson does Peter
Jackson love these big sweeping shots
that will make you a little dizzy but
not because it's shaky cam because like
you're gonna see a big sweeping chat
where you two go up we're going to go
down and like that there's a fabulous
gun does the same thing and like it for
the most what I enjoy there was a few
sloppy shots from like okay I've seen
this and every other actuary but there
was some impressive shots of my system
main I think he knows that the the sets
and the
and stuff r it can't just out there it
has to be composed nice too you know we
get this shit that looks cool at first
at these weird white circles and spheres
and curves and stuff like that and that
looks neat but most you know filmmakers
with just okay well we got this cool set
we don't need to go overboard and stuff
like that but you're there for a while
so he will get these interesting shots
and he will get these nice angles and
there's one thing to deal with a 3d go
we saw this in 3d in season three don't
fucking bother ya know get everything
the Star Wars trailer I got a
Transformers trailer where just looks
like there was almost no 3d it always
play I thought this was even pretty
it's not great but fuck it just it's
such a bright colorful movie let's put
these dark glasses up and then we had to
sit in an angle in the eye man you know
I was just getting a headache I start
closing one eye for a while just you
know I differ yeah you were like two
seats over CBS guy yeah let me run this
very far it was like assigned seating
and we got the tickets a little later so
we were on the very far left and I'm
just like trying to watch it just
getting a headache right but there was
one thing they did I thought it was very
clever because this is a trick maybe
you've noticed where they'll have the
you know when it goes to the big action
scene so get rid of the black bars on
top and make it seem bigger but
sometimes what we'll do is that they'll
have the black bars and the 3d will go
beyond the black bars I get some dust as
long it will go beyond the black bars
okay that's been dust
honestly it's surprisingly not that
impressive you think it'd be more wild
but it's usually not but they there's
one that was very impressive where is
the blue guys ship I think I forgot
taken over and it's lying in the black
bars and it flies outside the black bars
and takes up the whole ship in
transition transitions you in a IMAX
shot I was brilliant I didn't even
notice just because I don't know if 3d
to me is distracting I think you could
probably see it not in 3d because I'm
but I even noticing because I'm it's
just get ahead that's the one shot and I
said okay that was a really clever three
they cremate they cremate somebody in
space basically uh a little Viking
funeral type thing and everything and
the ashes like scatter and just like go
right in
face I'm like that's our what we thought
somebody was like fiery ashes like right
I just want to put so I I don't know I I
agree you don't need to see it in 3d but
it is good 3d uh but but it's not great
it's not that no you asked me I think
it's good the gold is weird as it is the
gold standards for me are still avatar I
can say which one about the movie I
thought the 3d was great all things
still how to train your dragon thank you
go if you know I thought was for you go
with RIT yes so this I didn't think this
was anywhere near like no but it's not
bad it's uh it's decent I don't think
it's great but the movie is great I love
the movie um ya know I is is it XS sure
are there parts where the pacing is
really kind of laborious sure did I care
no like I don't know it reminds me of
dread Jurassic Park I think is always a
great example like if you give me like
five minutes I could give you a hundred
things wrong with Jurassic Park like and
it's true there's like that is not a
perfect movie there hundred things are
like we reviewed it I mean it was a
movie I saw the most in theaters it's I
still will throw it on any time to be
immensely entertained I feel like this
is the same thing is that even though
there's issues with this I'm immensely
entertained yeah more so than even in
the majority of Marvel movies yeah I I
really loved it I can i I saw the first
one once I know what have fun I be more
than happy to watch it as a couple but I
know I might put this one for me
I'm sure it's a sacrilege those Avengers
fans up there but I would put this one
on the same level as Avengers hmm but I
like the first guardians of the galaxy
more than the Avengers hmm
I'm curious it yeah I'm curious if fans
are gonna like this one more the first
one more I can't see many people getting
like upset at this one unless there's
some sort of major detail to change from
the comic but must be doing even though
the comic time guarding the galaxy gotta
lights the characters in this more there
was definitely a lot more character
development I felt like I knew them
better and that was good the sacrifice
was it was not as
ah haha whiz-bang entertaining Layton
you had to sit down and actually listen
to these characters and sometimes it
works and there are other times there
was like I don't know about myself and
see what time it is like so but it I
still liked it so I don't know it's like
it'll maybe apples and oranges I know
one's better than the other but you know
because the first one didn't have a lot
of character everybody goes with Groot
what the fuck is this character yeah
yeah there's like everybody loves GRU -
that's the one with the probably the
least character like we were it's like
this movie does technically kind of have
the same problems just kind of in
slightly different ways I think you're
either gonna grab towards toward one or
the other
because everything you're saying it's
like that's like exactly what I thought
of the first off I'm just like man just
seems a little clunky and that came out
of nowhere and there there are times
where there's talking you don't need it
but it's like what you're saying is I
know you asked me which one had more
depth and meaning to it I would say this
one hand down I mean not even like I
wouldn't have to think about it well of
course is one what do you think open
like but if you ask me which one I would
probably rather just throw on any time
of day
would I be more likely to go to probably
the first one mmm yeah I I like this one
better they're both on their bow down
bow right anyway enjoyable um so yeah
Kathy and Marvel what the hell it's an
ogre and here's cross no wonder one
that's all I gotta say yeah it's just so
weird it's like we've never seen a
studio his I mean just this hard this
good this consistently and with such a
similar formula we were saying yeah we
know this formula but it's still so
entertaining and so much fun and I look
forward to them there weren't even that
much uh you know it's almost like
they're what DC does on television like
what we know what's funny - it's just
real quick if there's talk about um I
think like the Wonder Woman movie
they're saying well it's not giving as
much advertising as it should and that
now it still has like a month this I
felt that first trailer was huge and
then I I don't know maybe cuz we don't
have cable anymore we got rid of it like
I see
Watchmen I totally forgot it oh yeah I
have like online and I okay good cuz I
haven't seen that much of it uh but when
we went to the theater I needed to sold
out and a jam-packed so maybe it is one
of the things and the DC movies are hit
you know they're all hit so maybe
there's kind of this idea it's like well
we don't need to advantage or it's hard
because it's like you just know what
kind of goes I don't want to come into
the whole one room in advertising I'm
just always like who knows because it's
WB and there's such a shit show you know
I think that we need to make that
distinction a little like we always say
DC but really this is a WB problem
oh my I think when it comes to advertise
light I don't know I feel like whatever
the is going on over there like it ain't
good and we suffer because of it so
let's well yeah we get studio notes for
Suicide Squad in that movie the trailers
for the DC movies always look good
Wonder Woman that's my concern it's like
all the our trailers look good too so
yours open one on saying more the lack
of advertising is the same studio that
Iron Giant they didn't promote at all my
first mentor target open rate and oh and
Batman's abandoned every greatest fan
mail movies of all time you know they
didn't promote some who knows WB they
suck oh it to say I don't want to be -
crappy people Oh
but with again with like anything now
you know we've all been accused of like
taking money from Disney there you go
apparently WB is paying you yeah I like
him fine uh honest okay if there is like
money they don't tell you I would love
is out the case because this is the
easiest job it's like yeah it's just
crazy know these aren't already crying
UB has been like as the studio's they've
made some great films my problem is
whatever the studio culture is and when
it comes to promoting films and stuff I
don't know what the hell goes on over
there again I you think like the Matrix
movies too and stuff like that again
yeah I feel like they for some reason
they're always just even on Hobbit
movies that's weird I think that's very
hot booked three Hobbit movies like you
know and you could say the same like the
how Sony and Fox have handled their
comic book franchises do like eyes it's
too much Marvel DC it's the studio that
owns and I don't know if it's just
Disney's experience in this arena like
formula is me somewhere not and overall
because they used to be like ah say or
visit Disney or yeah yeah oh no they
were a shit show and then they had
things they were a shit show again the
after uh you know later I for years yeah
yeah what's on erectus going away and
stuff yeah but now they're they're just
like crazy knows because none of these
rebooted them any that's the urban is an
actual Disney property says Disney owns
it's been crazy with you but it was
something that they bought somewhere
else like Marvel or Star Wars it's been
pretty decent I don't know I don't know
like the doesn't Zootopia to the
frozen's and the you know on no no no
what's that okay
those are original ideas I'm talking
about their old business cycle a place
yeah nothing everybody me you would not
hear me saying what I said about like
jungleboy
your beauty in the be what the sense
instead of money have you got angry
calls I know were you living you ever
want to see your wife again
funny where'd you go yeah mess it up
there there's a weird teacher is okay
it's late um and we dig it out of it
very weird but very good movie yeah no
well that is the thing this is
exhausting Ellis's even the end credits
were fun yeah no idea I'm going i all
the little odd you know
Easter Egg there are way and the credit
yeah the little things that they have at
the end
area that is I'm happy to see Stallone's
going to be in a Marvel movie but I
don't know what that group is or that
team is I don't know what yeah I didn't
either I don't know what that coal baby
what's our problem is and the problems
were now stretching into parts of the
Marvel Universe that I have yeah I heard
that I eyes are never read to begin with
or completely forgotten because I even
like opened up a comic book since 1995
so yeah so I did it but I couldn't
that's the weird thing like I'm
beginning a diet like me and I'm just
like but it makes it more fun for me you
know I need to discover it I mean
they've been hitting some pretty
consistent and you know who did can you
right after you get to discover it so uh
yeah that's about this go check it out
it's a lot of fun it was a good movie
see if you like the first one you'll
probably like you're saying he's in the
a category I'm in the bead but yeah
let's be a movie this and anything
higher than a b-minus nowadays yeah well
being like the greatest thing on the
planet to me so definitely go check out
Mike
you